so that leaves me to the next fight
where if you watch the companion or you
watched uh shop show last week I said if
Sean O'Malley wins he's gonna be the
conversation no matter what happens with
the other two fights the main event
co-main event I ca I I stick by that
because Sean O'Malley's definitely the
topic of conversation Monday morning on
October 24th when the fight was on
Saturday
is the topic of conversation for a
variety of reasons a the way he won a
the controversial way he won with the
judge's decisions what decision
um and then also C to thirdly to that
point is he's also the biggest star on
the card and he did win so it checks all
boxes controversy which the UFC loves in
the kimmarket check the star the the
young line the colorful line with pink
hair that talks all the stuff and is
very
um you know dominant on social media and
twitch check you know and then also the
biggest check to me the biggest takeaway
from all this besides all the garbage
going online right now and all the hate
that Sugar Sean's getting is
he's the real deal
he's the real deal and he's an elite
fighter
so and I I text Sean O'Malley this this
morning you know guys that get a lot of
hate I have my black belt and hate I
have my master master degree dealing
with haters
and I I tell Sean O'Malley this this is
how I approach it if what they're hating
on right now infuriates them with sugar
Shawn gives you a lot of Reason to Hate
About troll guys you know Peter Young
won't touch me obviously that's trolling
he knows he's gonna get touched in a
three-round fight with Peter John the
number one bantamweight on the world of
coach of course you can't touch he's
doing that to get a rise out of you guys
he's trolling you right he's that's what
he does so he's giving you a lot of
reasons to be mad and be madame
but if you thought you didn't like Suga
Sean before
well now the narrative on him was
oh he's just getting these
you know Snowball Fight and he's not
real the UFC just wants to put him up
there he doesn't really have the skill
set he's not Elite well if you were mad
on before I'm gonna give you a lot more
reason to be mad at me now so for sugar
Shawn's sake if you hate him before and
your narrative was he's not a real
fighter he hasn't beat anybody he can't
be anybody in the top five he's never
gonna fight for a title he's not that
good of a striker he's not Elite blah
blah
well that's all gone
that's all gone there's no way even if
you can't stand sugar Sean there's no
way you can watch that fight and go he
doesn't deserve to be in there with the
top three guys in the world
because not only did he
show out and put on a great fight even
if he lost that decision you can't tell
he's not a top five Talent even if the
judges
sided with the majority of what the fan
base and the the MMA quote unquote
experts think which there's really not a
lot of experts in this space experts are
such a loose term when it comes to
sports so new but people that cover it
most of the people that cover it when
it's MMA fighting MMA junkie sheer dog
you name it all those things ESPN guys
all those major you know media Outlets
all scored it for Peter Young
let's say that it did go perion's way
even if it did you still can't sit and
tell me that Sugar Shawn is an elite
he proved all you guys wrong all the
haters wrong that he is an elite
high-level UFC fighter matter of fact
now he's the elite he's top three easily
as far as striking goes there's a reason
Peter Young was shooting so much
and it ain't because he wanted to
because he's getting pieced up on the
feet
by a guy who's ranked number 11 you're
ranked number one
Peter Young's known for a striking right
he's not his go-to isn't wrestling his
go-to usually is on the feet his
footwork wearing the guy out throwing
combinations knocking guys out didn't
happen when sugar Shawn did it
should Sean's Elite
so if you guys want some to hate on man
you can take a big chunk out of it now
he's just getting started
so if you woke up smart on the wrong
side of the bed and you're upset that
this guy with pink hair the rainbow hair
and the tattoos and he's hanging out
Takashi six nine if you hate him before
he's just getting started you have a lot
of animosity towards that man now
because if he thought he was big before
he just beat the number one bantamweight
in the world
no matter how you feel about it he beat
him
but let's talk about numbers let's just
talk about the fight
in our sport there's always these terms
that get popular and become this
regurgitating theme because people don't
think for themselves so it's oh he's
chinny right that for a long time he's
chinny he's Jenny Cheney was a thing
Chin Chin Chin was the thing I'm not
saying my producer I'm talking about if
a guy lost whether he had you know 10
Knockouts and was on ten fight win
streak he gets clipped oh he's Cheney
it's this whole chin thing that kind of
went away people got more educated it's
very rare they use it maybe it's a
veteran and you know and he is getting
knocked out like a an example of a
person where we say their Chin's gone
would be Bigfoot Silva right that guy I
will accept if you say he's chinny that
works in that case for the rest guys
doesn't really work and the audience
moved on from and got more educated so
we stopped using that well now the new
term is he got robbed It's a Robbery
whether it's a decision whatever Split
Decision majority decision oh he got
robbed I don't don't think you guys know
what the term robbery means if you're
going around throwing that term out
there especially in the case of sugar
Shawn O'Malley and Peter Yount nobody
got robbed nothing is a robbery here it
was a split decision a robbery would be
a guy who clearly wins three or five
rounds clearly dominates
and then the judges give it the complete
other way the complete other way 30-27
50 you know whatever 50 45 that's a
robbery it's like Jesus Christ robbery
for example for you guys that like to
use the term would be in the sport of
box and it'd be uh Canelo versus Triple
G the first one that's robbery Triple G
definitely won that but they had the fix
was in for Canelo all good he did it
then he ended up you know the second
fight you could also call a robbery the
third one you can the Canelo valid
himself and beat him there even though
he was a lot older either way that first
one would be a robbery a robbery would
be uh Robbie Lawler Condit for the belt
a robbery would be
Machida Shogun Rua the those are
robberies where it's clear as day the
other guy dominant a robbery would be
for you guys to use it so you sound
educated when you use the term robbery
because you're using it so much it's
lost it's meaning because now every
robbery robbery oh that's a robbery no
it's not you know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about a robbery would be Johnny
Hendricks GSP that's a robbery
this is narari Johnny Hendricks no
matter who you talk to you look at that
he won multiple multiple rounds the
majority of the rounds you might give
GSP one there I could see maybe two sure
as hell and no fast at three but these
judges did that would be a robbery this
is not a robbery if you go back and
watch fight which I have four times now
before I came in and made this point
if you go through the rounds one two and
three it would be tough if you take it
without a biased Viewpoint with however
you feel about sugar Sean
if you know a thing or two about the way
they score fights they have a criteria
so it takes out the bias of the fight so
if you went into the fight a huge Peter
yawn fan it doesn't matter you have to
score it on these certain topics you
have to these certain things cage
control uh damage being number one just
so let's make it clear before I make
this point
for the judges the number one
determining factor of a round is damage
right remember that before I make this
case the number one criteria in order to
decide who wins a round is damaged not
takedowns not only guy down not octagon
control not aggressiveness
not submissions thrown not kicks landed
not punches thrown the number one thing
you have got to get this in your goddamn
Minds to say robbery the number one
thing is damage
so let's go through the fight
first round is where you're gonna have
most controversy first round even though
Peter John land that big takedown what
did he do with that takedown if you got
to put your yourself in the mind of the
judge at UFC ad in Abu Dhabi in the
arena there and if you're judging this
thing and you're going based off damage
which is number one indicator how we
judge around number one right
you go through that first round and the
reason why the first round is so
important because the second and third
are clear as day who won those rounds
second round was Peter John third
round's sugar Sean easy easy to score
those are easy fight score if you sit
back and analyze those rounds and go
based off the judging criteria which I
did not design I have nothing to do with
it but that's how they judge the fight
so if you're gonna judge the fight based
the way the judges do it which is the
only thing that matters because that who
decides who wins and loses a fight based
off the Damage Done
of those rounds two and three the second
would go to Peter Young although damage
wasn't really inflicted but although
remember so damage number one if there's
no damage being done you got to go down
the line so next would be takedown's
control all right so if no damage done
in the second round takedown's control
second round Peter yon land those
takedowns controlled him for the most
part not a lot of damage was done though
down there so we can't really judge it
based off damage so then we go to
control and takedowns with two most
significant things in that second round
that's Peter on all day say ground Peter
on all day
third round if we go to the number one
judging criteria which is damage
it's not even close in if you want to
and doesn't always tell the The
Narrative of a fight but if you want to
go the copy strike numbers I think Sugar
Land like 40 to 15 or some [ __ ] like
that those aren't exact numbers but it
was in that Realm also the knee which
split Peter Yan open in the third round
was the most significant damage done in
15 minutes of that fight you would give
sugar Shawn that third round clear as
day second round peon Clara's Day first
round that's where you have an argument
now when I was watching it it always
take with a grain of salt if you're
watching uh the Salt Lake City fight
campaign right now after you listen to
this rant if you're watching I go well
you scored it for Peter Yan I did but
remember I'm barely paying attention all
I see I I see some shots landed if it's
a big one and everyone goes oh I'll see
that I'm drinking
all right there's some tiger thick
flowing through my veins and third of
all
I just see the takedown the control and
what I I'm looking but then remember I'm
the captain of the ship I have to manage
to make sure the show is entertaining
getting Frank to talking and Jessica
talk I gotta manage these different
personalities while trying to pay
attention to the fight so never take
what I say in the moment of a fight
companion to Heart
so what I do so I have a better
perspective on it is I go back and watch
those fights that are close so I can
really pay attention I I don't listen in
the commentating because that can also
and I haven't listened to commentating
on this
I never do especially when I'm before
I'm breaking a fight down I listen to it
in silence when the kids go to I drop
them off at school I come back I watch
the fight over and over and over thank
God this one's 15 minutes so I was
allowed to watch it a few times
so when you watch it and you're not
you're not swayed by the commentating
because a lot of times when I hear
robbery I go I bet the commentating was
also a little biased towards a certain
fighter because that because again a lot
of people sheep they don't think for
themselves they hear the commentary from
these experts legit experts and they can
skew or sway a fan base so I don't
engage in that I don't listen to any of
that so if you take out your bias you
take out the commentating you watch that
fight you watch the first round punches
landed kicks landed the body shots
if you're old school like me and I
always favor wrestling and grappling
usually in fights
you're going to give it to Peter yon but
if you watch it the way they judge and
fight which all that matters you might
say well he didn't stop the takedown he
didn't do this and Peter John control
for you know this amount of time it does
not matter the way they judge the fight
is significant strikes landed and damage
done and and sugar Shawn did that in
that first round and that's why I would
give the first round to Sugar Shawn
second round Peter Yan third round sugar
Shawn all [ __ ] day if you don't give
the third round of sugar Sean you're
just a hater and you're biased and
that's all good I've been there but it's
not real you know it's real the judges
score card and the judge's scorecard had
it 29 28 for Suga 28.29 for Peter Young
and then the most important one 2928 for
Suga which gave sugar the split decision
over the number one band to wait in the
world
and not only did it validate how [ __ ]
good sugar Shawn is but it gave all you
haters out there more
to chew on so if you hated sugar Shawn
before I'm telling you the kids just
getting started this was his first big
test and he passed it with flying colors
Win Lose or Draw
doesn't matter
sugar Shawn is Elite and you guys hate
that and one of the things that makes
sugar Sean so polarizing and so massive
and popular is because all this talk all
this noise online which none of it
matters all this talk all this stuff
just feeds in you're doing promo for
sugar
all the hate anybody gets whether it's a
comic an athlete a fighter a a an actor
you're giving them free promo because
most people think for themselves so you
might cut a YouTube video and go show
you Sean's worst fighter ever someone's
gonna click on that your sugar Sean's in
your mind sugar Sean's out there you're
putting more sugar Shawn content out
there more people than regurgitate that
more people need to get that but most of
them form their own opinion but you're
just giving him free promo you're
getting free promo makes them bigger
makes the machine bigger makes people
want to see them win or lose makes them
want to see him Floyd Mayweather
pay-per-view model we weren't tuning in
for the most part to see Floyd
Mayweather put on an amazing performance
because he fought pretty safe he's so
damn good at he's the best of all time
you're tuned in to see him lose
Floyd Mayweather's bank account does not
care if you're 80 bucks for that pay for
you came because you hate them or
because you love them the bank accounts
don't care sugar Sean's bank account and
his negotiation with the UFC does not
care
whether it's hey these million people
tune in because they want to see sugar
lose cool
these million people tuned in because I
don't see sugar win cool it's all the
same at the end of the day
so your hate for sugar Shawn is helping
him it's building the machine it's
fueling the rocket ship that is tied to
his back now that not only did he prove
every single body wrong
but now there's nothing you can do to
take this away from however you feel
about it on Monday morning sugar Shawn
O'Malley will be ranked probably in the
top two in the world in the bantamweight
division he's not in the top two that's
just [ __ ]
because the guy is clearly Elite and you
guys didn't think he was and you were
wrong
so if you hate them before man he's
gonna be he has a lot more work to do
you hate him even more now because he is
getting his next title shot he is going
to be the next guy in line to get Tire
shot
now for sugar Sean
when he um got on the mic
exhausted three rounds he goes I'll have
to watch fight I'm not even sure I won
that fight I don't know if I deserve a
title shot I'll have to watch it before
I talk about it trust me he's gonna get
back on his social media which is bigger
than the crowd that was tuned into UFC
280 he's gonna get on there I bet you he
will vindicate himself and say I
definitely after watching I definitely
deserve it
because he probably feels a certain type
of way because he's never been that type
of fight before so he didn't do the
usual sugar thing where I didn't get
touched I told you to smoke him because
he was an actual dog fight with the
number one bent weight in the world and
he beat him no he didn't doesn't matter
the judges gave it to him your opinion
on this does not matter my opinion on
this does not matter at the end of the
day
and throughout history when we look back
on this fight card all it says no matter
how you feel about it how you scored at
home how you and your drunk buddy scored
it who have never fought before how all
you guys scored it does not matter
sugar Sean won this fight
those are in the record books
that's all that matters
Talk Amongst yourselves
talks amongst Twitter talks amongst read
it talks amongst share dog talks amongst
the forums talks among YouTube comments
all that noise builds these guys that
you hate even bigger even bigger you're
helping the machine out you're helping
put money and show your Sean's pocket so
continue on shout out to show your Sean
you did it buddy you did it now was it a
Connor Aldo moment no
there's not a Conor Auto moment because
he didn't just starch them and walk off
after 19 seconds
I think this was more important for
sugar Shawn fans because
him going three hard rounds and being
controversial going back and forth we
see Suga he looked tired in that second
round came out the third one the third
significantly won the third that huge
need Landing huge punches wobbling Peter
Young we've never seen Peter John so
much trouble he was damn near about to
get finished getting rocked so many
times
taking sugar down which we expected but
then really not doing anything with it
should just take down defense actually
better than we thought Sugar's defense
down there is actually better than we
thought if you're a fan of sugar we
didn't want the 19 second knockout we
wanted to see if sugar was a stock if he
was a New York a stock right if he's on
the stock market here's the thing for
all those sugar fans out there he
validated everybody's kind of questions
about sugar is he Elite can we
bet on this guy can we Bank on this guy
when the going gets rough and it's not
going his way and gets taken down and if
if he gets rocked on the feet how's he
going to respond we've never seen it so
it's hard to bet on that guy well guess
what we've seen it we've seen it we know
when he gets the title shot against
algerman Sterling when the going gets
rough suga's not going to quit I'll bet
on that guy he's a Fighter's fighter
he's a real fighter I know he has purple
hair pink here where the hell it is
today and rainbow hair but then day you
strip all that down you take the chains
off the tattoos off the twitch off the
hanging out the appearances with Takashi
69 and whoever the hell else he's
hanging out with and his him his coaches
are wild and all that stuff you strip
all that away at the end of the day
after UFC 280 there's no doubt about it
sugar Shawn is one of the best batting
weights on the planet hands down and I
can't wait for that for him to get title
shot now
after watching that fight is Al Jermaine
a terror fight probably
he's gonna have his hands full there
but at least I know I can bet on him I
know he's not going to give up I know
when it comes to the feet he can
definitely outstrike algebrae when it's
on the feet I'd be willing to bet
Sterling's not going to play that game
there's a reason for that because you
can watch that Peter on tape go kick him
fight for the first time ever and suga's
career even if you hate the guy you
watch the 15 minutes of him find Peter
Young there's not a single person in the
world that can't say sugar Shawn's not
Elite and he can't fight that narrows
out the window what else you got
what else you guys are gonna run on
you gotta come up with something what is
it he didn't Pete he didn't beat Peter
Young that's all noise doesn't matter he
did he did
straight up doesn't matter what you
think he beat him what else you got keep
going you gotta haters out there you
gotta come up with something better for
sugar what else you got
come on you gotta come up with something
you should all get together I don't know
where you guys meet whether it's a PF
Chang's Starbucks I don't know where the
hell all these sugars haters meet you
get whoever the ring leader is and he
got a new narrative because a narrative
oh he's not a real fighter he's not
Elite that doesn't work here he didn't
win that doesn't work here
yes and there could be uh he's being
beat up by Al Jermaine Sterling all
right that's fine that's a fun one do
that
shout out to Sugar Shawn you [ __ ] did
it dude good for you if you're into
thick boys
like subscribe comment
and God bless America oh that's not my
big one just kidding